system today and i think we've talked
with some of you about this before i
doubt whether anyone would think that 12
years is enough in the 21st second half
of the 20th second quarter of the 21st
century and so what we do here is uh we
uh we want to have the best educated
workforce and that's why
universal pre-k is going to mean so much
and it also
uh you know it also increases
exponentially the prospect of
that child uh being able to no matter
what her background or his or her
background get through 12 years of
school and then go on
almost half go on to a two or four year
college
and
students show
these studies are been done by a lot of
the great universities that
that it's gonna it's a i think it's an
economic necessity to have the best
educated workforce
and take clean energy manufacturing
we're uh we're bringing american
manufacturing back i should say y'all
are bringing american manufacturing back
and uh and we're we're helping along the
way here
the industrial midwest believe it or not
it's coming back i got here
when i was uh 20 to 30 years old and
industrial midwest was still going
strong
but it's coming back
doing some of the most sophisticated
manufacturing in the world
a real breakthrough began last year when
mary mary mary bearer excuse me mary for
referring your fruit
um
i said it again and jim and jim farley
of ford gm and ford
and
some of the key labor leaders announced
that they're moving to
all-electric
future for vehicles
just yesterday mary and gm announced a 7
billion investment
to build electric vehicles in michigan
it's going to create 4 000 new jobs and
last year i was up at ford's plan in
dearborn michigan to see that
all-electric 150 as part of ford's
11 billion dollar investment in electric
vehicles that's going to create 11 000
new jobs
and as part of the over 100 billion
dollars committed over the last year
american auto manufacturing is going to
build electric vehicles and batteries
and build them in the united states of
america and we all know how important it
is to man to manufacturing to have the
necessary component parts here in
america made in america and last week i
point out that
intel announced a 20 billion plan to
build a semiconductor manufacturing
facility in ohio
one of the largest of its kind in our
nation's history
it's going to create 10 000 jobs and i
might add you know one of the reasons
for inflation being high is it is one
third of the reason inflation is up is
the cost of
vehicles and the reason the cost of
vehicles is up they don't have the
component parts meeting
significantly the semiconductors
last year
other top manufacturers committed 80
billion dollars
in new semiconductor facilities across
the nation beyond what intel just
announced
it's going to create thousands of jobs
thousands of good paying jobs and my my
new infrastructure law is going to build
out more than 50 000 charging stations
for electric vehicles across the country
creating better paying jobs for
thousands of workers and the ibew is
going to be really very busy putting all
those in all over the country
and that's just to start our buildback
better plan i say ours
is uh is going to do even more in my
view
combined uh within the infrastructure
law we're making the biggest investment
in clean energy manufacturing ever in
american history
this is about here and now and the
future
you know
our buildback better plan is paid for it
doesn't increase the deficit and maybe
the best news of all it will actually
help alleviate inflation
the fact that 17 nobel laureates and
economics say that the buildback better
initiative will ease inflation pressures
in the future
is is somewhat reassuring the bottom
line is
a lot of folks refer to this as just
social spending
well i see it but i see it this way the
buildback better plan lowers prices for
families
and gets people working
it creates the best educated workforce
and hopefully in the world and ensures
it remain the most dynamic and
productive economy in the world
it's good for families it's good for the
economy and it's good for the country
and so i'm grateful for the support of
the ceos that are here i know they're
somewhat busy
to say the least
and they represent a broad spectrum of
the economy
and employ workers across the country
from senior executives to
high skill entry level workers and so i
look forward to the input today that
we're going to be having here and
their expertise and now i'm going to
let's get started with this meeting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys let's go let's go thank
you
[Music]
thanks so much
every
justin
has the right opportunity to decide what
he or she is going to do to announce it
on their own
there has been no announcement from
justice breyer let him make whatever
statement he's going to make and i'll be
happy to talk about it later thank you
so much
mr president
so
i'll be happy to talk about this later
i'm going to get into this issue okay
we're going to start we're going to
start by asking
tom
uh tom limberger to uh to offer your
thoughts please
yeah thank you mr president it's an
honor to go to the supreme court tom
i'm just going to demurr on that one but
it's really an honor to be here thank
you for inviting me to this event and
and i just want to say that guys let's
let's let's
i just i just wanted to say that
that uh
i i think that climate change is the
existential crisis of our time
and i know that i would not want to be
sitting in my living room with my kids
and grandkids and not say that i made
every effort i could to address it and
working at a company like cummins which
has been an innovator for a long time
i think we can do make a big investment
and a big
effort to address climate change in some
of the toughest to abate sections in the
economy trucks
construction equipment and things like
that and that includes batteries
hydrogen fuel cells and other
important technologies and we are
investing significantly in those but we
can't do it alone the truth is we need
investments tax credits and the
buildback better act
for hydrogen and clean trucks will play
a big role
in getting all of us to invest in
infrastructure and other things that we
need
to get this going and i just want to say
that
i think we're out of time
my view is that we're out of time
to protect our climate and we're out of
time to make sure that american
companies are the ones that lead the
world in these technologies
when we invest
we can win and we can create jobs
for our workers here in the united
states that's what we intend to do at
cummins and i think that's what all of
us can do if we invest in climate change
technologies now if we wait not only do
we harm the climate but we make sure
that we're the we're not the winners in
global competitiveness
thank you for allowing me to did you
know the buildback better plan is over
500 billion
and climate change initiatives including
the tax credits you referred to
uh you're one of the world's largest
engine manufacturers
and uh
they tell me you have a nearly
what 60 000 employees now
and uh you know you've talked about
being raised i read a little about you
talk about being raised by a single mom
who worked uh
through school caring for you and your
brother
and uh and for your employees uh and for
your mom at home
what
is the benefit
of the build back better provisions
relating to
um child care
i mean from a business standpoint
mr president i would just say that my
mom would be incredibly honored to even
be in the conversation at this table
thank you for bringing her up hey let me
tell you
she's a big part of my life and i'm very
grateful to her i know that she has
she's proud of me for playing the role
that i'm playing um in the economy and
especially for addressing such an
important issue as as climate change and
um you know i i'm
i would just say that we're gonna make
whatever investments we need to to do
our part
and i really appreciate the efforts of
this administration to put those
put the climate first in this build that
better act and i hope
um that that that
that our leaders can see see the the
future that and the importance of the
future and the investments that need to
be made to make sure climate change is
addressed well tom on the part of the
program is referred to as a social
spending
what
if there is if you think there is
what from a business standpoint
does the child care
the being able to have the child care
tax credit
um so you're going to have instead of
paying 14 grand for example if you live
in new york or wherever you're paying
half of that what does that do from a
business perspective for you
at cummins we've always been
thoughtful about not only how our
business does but how our communities do
and we think that none of our company
can never be stronger than the
communities in which we live and work
and and there's no question that the
families that
work for our company
are
child care is a significant burden to
them uh so we it's clearly an issue that
needs to be addressed
um and there's there's no question that
we hear about it a lot we we offered new
benefits
in our company uh for both child care
and for
for family leave and i get more notes
about that than pretty much anything
else i do i'll bet you do
all right well
thank you uh
now uh
brad i want to thank you for being here
the pandemic hit your uh
your
hit your workers
and uh
and hard and uh working parents hard
tell me about how your support
microsoft
is looking at workforce
and the price
and the pieces
of the buildback better agenda that
would advance the goals of your company
i mean what what's the relationship
between
this
piece of my program
and
benefiting your company well i think
there's a very important connection mr
president between the pieces of
buildback better
and what matters not just to microsoft's
business
but to every american business the truth
is our business is hugely dependent on
the success of every part of the economy
yeah we announced our earnings yesterday
afternoon i think they've
had some positive effect on the markets
today and what our earnings reflect is
fundamentally demand of the american
economy is strong but supply is
constrained and i think part of the
issue goes
precisely to what you were just asking
about
you know what we see is that we need to
do more to help bring americans back to
work
and one of the key ingredients that we
see whether it's for our employees or
everybody's employees
is that people can only come back to
work
if they have a way to take care of their
children
and in america today there are two
groups of people who are challenged when
it comes to taking care of their
children
for some they can't afford
to pay
for child care and that's where the
provisions build back better that focus
on low-income people who want to work or
who want to get training to work i think
is precisely focused on what matters to
people the second group of people that
are is challenged is people who can
afford to pay for child care but what
they're finding is that child care
centers themselves don't have enough
trained people and your initiative
addresses that as well
and so from our perspective buildback
better will help address supply
shortages in the short run well i will
also say building a long-term foundation
for another critical element that
business needs namely people with the
skills to do the jobs that we are
creating and if there's one thing we've
learned is that the best remedy for some
of the most acute skill shortages
is to enlist the nation's community
colleges and mobilize them for the
training that's needed which buildback
better would do and when you couple that
with the investment in pell grants
something that i think so many of us
benefited from in terms of our ability
to get the skills to succeed
that is the skills that we owe the next
generation of students as well
i would offer a full-throated
endorsement of the climate provisions as
well
in short i think that does not only what
the world needs by inventing the
technology in america that literally
will help us protect the planet but it
will ensure that the jobs of the future
are created in the united states as well
so across the board
i don't think we talked about that
enough yeah provision that
if we the technology that we by
investing
are going to
develop
that become export capacity
export matters that grow the american
economy beyond
merely what it does relating to the
environment here at home
and i think we're better positioned than
any
any country in the world to do it if we
invest
i couldn't agree more you know it's
digital technology will play a role
across the board so we at microsoft see
this but more than that
this is things like the long-duration
battery storage
that will equip the automobiles of the
future it's a sustainable aviation fuel
that our airlines and aircraft
manufacturers need it's really every
sector of the economy and perhaps most
especially the future
of power generation
well thank you very much brad for uh
for being here and what you're doing now
uh
mary uh i'm always talking about
corvettes i don't make fort or anybody
else upset
but uh
um i might point out you're uh
when i went to dearborn driving that
uh you know uh was up there
i don't know man
it uh
i think the press thought i was crazy i
enjoyed it so much going up and
uh your new ev factory and uh
and that uh that hummer
before i i talked about dearborn in the
f-150 but that that hummer
my lord you guys have you
seen this vehicle
it weighs three times what my corvette
weighs
when it was brand new the corvette was
zero to 60 in 5.2 seconds
this is about 4.1 actually models up to
zero to three seconds right in three
seconds
okay i'm looking for a job mary
but anyway uh all kidding aside uh
i'd like to
you know
what uh
what do you what can you tell me about
what the investments will make in this
legislation
would mean
to your business and your business
moving forward
absolutely well first of all again it is
an honor to be here today and be able to
speak about climate change and our
aligned goals as it relates to
converting to an all-electric future
and general motors is committed uh to
invest more than 35 billion dollars uh
to support electric vehicles and
autonomous vehicles by 2025.
just yesterday as you mentioned we uh
made an announcement to put seven
billion dollars more into the state of
michigan for affecting four facilities
converting one plant to electric truck
manufacturing as well as
uh two additional factories and then a
battery plant and so we are really
working to make sure as we make this
transformation to electric and do the
right thing for the environment that we
bring everybody along meaning that we
have products at many different price
points and people who participate in
this market can either new or use are
going to have the opportunity to afford
electric vehicles
to do that it takes
a good public-private partnership
because for us to make those investments
we need provisions uh especially the uh
the environmental provisions or the
climate provisions that are going to uh
uncapped ev credits we see
with ev credits that it does stimulate
the market and to get to the aggressive
greenhouse gas reduction goals that we
have
getting a strong demand is very
important already you know very
appreciative of what is in the
infrastructure bill to build out the ev
charging because that's another
important part as well
but then there's provisions for
advanced manufacturing and battery and
component manufacturing and it's vital
that we have that in the united states
to not only secure our future but to
have economic growth and to provide good
paying jobs so there are many provisions
um that are very important that are
going to allow us to advance and
accelerate the move to electric vehicles
so we look forward to working with you
and congress not only for
the ev tax credit and the advanced
manufacturing credits but also the chips
act the funding for the chips act it
really is a national imperative
without uh having the capability to have
and we've all lived through it over the
last year and continues into this year
without having the
ability to have that supply chain in
this country as well
that is going to hurt our ability to
lead whether it is in electric vehicles
autonomous vehicles and these are key
technologies for the future and it truly
is a global race
it really is and
as a
as a son of a man who
ran
the last 35 years was life a
ford dealership
and then a chevy dealership
um
the
um i uh
you're going to make a lot of difference
in people being able to make a living
again
i mean it really
really really does matter i mean i don't
i it's uh
it's consequential and i uh at any rate
but uh i thank you for
being here and what you have to say now
uh
so yeah brian yeah mr president with
your permission we're gonna shift to the
next uh section we're gonna ask the uh
uh press to leave and we're gonna focus
on going down into
some of the